c'est l'histoire d'un enfant devenu roi
par un invraisemblable tour de passe
passe presque un tour de magie le vieux
monde s'écroule d'un souffle et des
décombres survient l'avènement de manu
progrès au fil de cette enquête il ya
deux ou trois éléments sur mes yeux
marrons qui ne sont apparus plus
clairement il ya la volonté
le volontarisme incroyable c'est à dire
d'un jeune homme qui croit en lui en ses
capacités et en sa capacité à renverser
le cours des choses
il y a
le fait qu'il s'appuie sur un très petit
nombre de personnes
il ya un commando extrêmement restreint
autour de lui qui lui a permis de
conquérir le pouvoir
puis les kings qui l'aident à l'exercé
depuis il ya une cour de fidèles qui est
extrêmement restreinte en fait et il ya
une autre particularité c'est que ces
gens qui font partie de cette cour se
ressemblent énormément macro nargis en
marche forcée c'est une bande dessinée
que j'ai eu le plaisir de co écrire avec
thibaut soulcié le dessinateur qui est
paru chez glénat et qui raconte les 18
premiers mois du quinquennat d' emmanuel
macron depuis son élection son
installation à l'elysée avec un commando
de quelques fidèles qu'ils l'aident à
essayer de bâtir cette fameuse start-up
nacion l'avènement de ce qui est
présupposé être un nouveau monde
jusqu'à la crise des gilets jaunes et le
grand débat qu'il a inventée pour
essayer de se sortir de cette crise qui
a profondément ébranlé les pouvoirs
[Musique]
et c'est vrai qu emmanuel macron dès son
élection et dès le discours du soir de
son élection dans la cour du louvre a
devant la pyramide s'imposer comme un
formidable clients l'oeuvre l'oeuvre qui
suscite l'imagination et qui suscite
surtout l' envie d'écrire dessus basse
et emmanuel macron les mêmes c'est
d'abord une enquête journalistique donc
les faits eux ils sont réels les
déclarations le sont les mots utilisés
par les uns et les autres sont réels
c'est donc d'abord une bd enquête qui
raconte les coulisses du pouvoir
et puis on rajoute deux ou trois gags
deux ou trois caricature pour forcer un
peu le trait parce que toute façon le
dessin et la bande dessinée se prête à
ça
[Musique]